- [Rosie O'Donnell] Hi,
everybody! Hi, Kelly Clarkson!
- Hi Rosie.
- How are you? I haven't
seen you in 20 years.
- I'm literally so excited about this.
I am disappointed in
myself 'cause you know how
in your show you had the thing to come out
for people with short, like--
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yes.
- That was one of my favorite
things about your show,
'cause I'm so short, and
I, we need to work on that.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yeah.
Yeah. It was a good thing.
Although once William Shatner was there,
and it malfunctioned,
and his feet were, I guess not touching
and all of a sudden he slid down
right out of the chair on live TV.
- Well that's kind of funny as well.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yeah.
It was funny for a
moment but I was worried.
He's an elder gentleman, you know,
I thought, "There goes
William Shatner's back.
I just killed William Shatner."
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's amazing.
- Which you don't wanna do.
- We haven't seen each
other, you said, in 20 years.
- Right. - I don't even
know if you remember,
but we were on The Tonight Show.
- Of course I remember, yes.
- Okay. 'Cause I was, I actually went back
and looked at the interview,
'cause I was like,
"I know we ran into each other,"
but I was so annoying
because I was nervous.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] No, no.
- But I was so nervous 'cause I'm such a
look at my smile. I'm so excited.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] (laughs)
- [Kelly Clarkson] I literally, like,
every time someone says
'cause I never thought I'd have a TV show.
But it was interesting,
I connected with you.
You're such a fan of things.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yes.
- And you're like a true fan.
Like, I'm hoping to
like emulate that a bit.
- [Rosie O'Donnell]
Well you did say to me,
I don't know if you remember, you said,
"I hope to have a career like you."
- I did. I did! (laughs)
- [Rosie O'Donnell]
You did say that to me.
- But what's funny is I didn't
mean, like, a talk show.
I meant longevity, right?
Yeah. I was, I didn't even mean that.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] And I said to you,
"You're gonna. I know
it." And here you are.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I know. Thank you.
- You're welcome, it was me.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So what do you miss
about doing a talk show?
- Well, I miss the human interest segments
and what I love about your show
is how you focus on the human
interest segment so much.
Because there's only
so much of celebrities
you can see, without, you know
like, year five you're gonna be going,
"Oh my god ,it's that guy
from the soap opera again."
You know, it's kinda
hard to interview someone
nine or ten times.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- But the human interest
stories always made me cry
and broke my heart
and I was so happy to
give people the spotlight.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- For a moment. People
who deserve it, who never
really get it.
And I love how you guys
do that on this show.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's my favorite part.
Your show was live, though.
- Live every day.
- I mean, I, two words, they
could never make my show live
'cause I curse like a sailor.
That's three words.
- (laughs)
- There's like four words
to curse like a sailor.
But like, I don't know
if I could do it live.
That must have been really hard.
- Well I had so many
years as a standup comic
so that was really helpful.
But I really wanted to do it
because I didn't want
some studio executive
to come in and say, "You know,
"I didn't really like the
Dom DeLuise cooking segment.
"Would you do that again?"
You know, I didn't wanna
have to redo something
and try to make what's
spontaneous and real taped.
You know, I wanted to keep it as live
as a live performance of standup.
- Yeah.
- So that was sort of my choice.
And we did it in New York
so that we could go live to
all the earliest clearances.
- Yeah.
And I loved it that way.
I felt like that hour that I was
on TV was the funnest hour of my day.
- Not people so much are worried,
I worry for me and what
comes out of my mouth.
(laughs) I-
- Have you ever done anything that-
- I like to be able to edit me.
- I was gonna say, have
you ever done anything
where you told them "Take
that out." What I just said.
- Well, I went through a
pretty rough two years.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Where sometimes, look, we're human.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yes.
- And I would say something
like, "Maybe that wasn't
"maybe I shouldn't say that."
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, no, yeah.
I definitely have edited myself.
I think my mother appreciates
it as well. (laughs)
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yeah,
yeah. My family sometimes-
- We are different humans.
- Yeah. My family sometimes says to me,
"Did you have to tell them that?"
- You know-
- Oh, yeah.
- I'm like, well, everything
is, you know, material.
- But it's relatable.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Relatable.
- And I think it's relatable.
Everybody goes through
stuff like that. But it is fun though.
You do stand up, I'm a musician.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Yes.
- The live energy though,
you can't beat that.
- You can't beat it at all.
- That's why I love the
audience. At least we have
the audience, like you
get that interaction.
- Yeah. It's harder
for you, because I know
one time when Madonna was
playing at the big stadium
in London
she had, I was there with
her and she said, "Come here,
"come with me out on
the stage in the dark."
And I was like, "No, I don't wanna."
She goes, "No, before
they put the light on."
So I walked out just a
couple of feet on the stage
and the power of like Wembley Stadium
all screaming for you,
it literally almost moved my body back.
I thought, "No wonder
these rock stars sometimes
have a hard time coming down to earth
after getting that kind
of reaction from people.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- It was overwhelming to me.
I'm sure you've experienced that.
- I think it's just exciting.
I don't ever see it I guess.
I guess it's, it just seems
like a giant party for me.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- But the power of that kind of attention
focused on one human body.
- Yeah.
- You know, when, I don't
know were there 10,000
people in Wembley?
I don't even know.
Screaming and yelling or 50,000
whatever the number was at
the height of her career.
It was just like a tsunami.
- I feel like there's a different sound
at a Madonna concert than
a Kelly Clarkson concert.
- (laughs) Do you?
- I feel like maybe just a
little decibel difference.
I feel like maybe I've
never felt that power.
- I think you have.
- I feel my fans are really
awesome and they're loud
but I feel like there's
probably a difference between
like a Madonna show. Maybe.
You also had Koosh balls on your show.
- I did.
- So we got you some, 'cause I love you.
- They still make them?
- They do!
- I didn't know that.
- Yes.
- Now have you practiced with these?
- I have not.
- Okay, so who's got,
oh, right, up in the-
- Okay, I'm going up. I'm going up.
- Almost. Almost.
- Yeah! Why are you afraid of it, man?
- Yeah, don't be afraid.
It's not a hand grenade.
- It's not a fireball.
- Oh, for the top.
Here we go.
Yellow shirts.
- I'm doing one more.
Wait, you're doing more.
- Oh, I almost hit you in the head.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Wait, wait.
Can I make it to the band?
I don't even know if I can make it.
- Of course you can.
- I don't even know if I can make it.
- I'm gonna hit the drummer.
- No, I did it. I did it.
- Oh!
- You're amazing!
- Honey, I had years and years of this.
- You had years of practice.
- All right, let's get to
some commercials (laughs)
- I'll take out your keyboard player.
- That was the look at her
new series on Showtime.
It's called American Gigolo.
So is the show based on
the Richard Gear movie
from back in the day?
- It was, but it's not,
it doesn't really follow it very much.
Like I, that movie came out when I was 18
and it was like a highly sexual kind of
it wasn't my thing at the time.
- Yeah.
- And so I never had seen it.
And when I got the role,
they offered me the role
without having to audition
for the first time, Kelly.
- Wow.
- You made it.
- I made it.
- My agent called and
said, we just got an offer.
I go, "I don't have to
audition or meet anyone?"
"No. You just have to say yes."
- Wow.
- And it was the role that was originally
played by Hector Elizondo.
- You earned that, but go ahead.
- Hector Elizondo, who
was an amazing actor
in all those Gary Marshall
films and everything he did.
And they said, "You're
gonna play that part."
And I was like, "Are you
gonna change it at all?"
They go, "No. As it was written for a man
when they wrote this pilot script,
we're just gonna cast you in it instead."
So you get sort of a tough talkin''
60 year old LAPD detective
in homicide who has
about to retire and wants
to make everything right
in her career before she goes.
- Yeah. 'Cause that's a heavy
conversation you're having.
- Yeah. It's not like a comedy.
- No. But your first role
I remember seeing you in
as well is A League of their Own, right?
- Right.
- Have your kids seen it?
- [Rosie O'Donnell] Well,
you know what's funny?
My kids have no interest in
my career in any capacity.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Welcome.
- [Rosie O'Donnell] They never have.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- [Rosie O'Donnell]
Yes. So you understand.
So I, like you, when I started my show
had a little toddler running around.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And you know, they never saw anything.
I took them to see Tarzan when
I was Turk I was the monkey in that.
And so my son is sitting there
and he's four and the
other baby is two. Chelsea.
And in the middle of the movie
there's a quiet part, and
he stands on his chair,
he goes, "That monkey's my mama," you know
in front of the whole thing.
And I was like, "Yes. I didn't know
"you would get that."
But my son who's 23, Blakey, who is such a
he's just such a mush this kid.
He comes home from a party.
He goes, "Mom, you're
not gonna believe this."
I said, "What happened?"
He said, "John had on some movie
"and you were like a
teenager playing baseball
"and you sounded like Sylvester Stallone."
I go, "Blakey, that's
my most famous movie.
"That's how I became an
entertainer because of that movie."
And he said, "Yeah, I never saw it
"but it was weird seeing you that young."
- Oh my God. It is.
I never really thought about that.
But our kids looking back, like
especially there's so many YouTube videos
and so many clips to look at.
- Right. And they're so old now.
My kids go from twenty-seven, twenty five,
twenty-three, nineteen, and nine.
I have a nine year old.
I adopted at 50.
I thought I could get
a facelift or a baby.
So I took the baby, you know,
kept me young in a different way.
- And so how do you think
your parenting has changed
over the last year?
Like from the older ones
to the new, you know.
- So much. First of all, you know,
when you grow up in a, you know,
my mom had died and we
didn't have that much money
and my dad was, you know, troubled guy.
And so I wanted to provide
for my children every kind
of thing for childhood that I didn't have.
Like, you know, we had
those sneakers that were
attached in the store,
so you could never walk.
- 100% you try on and like hop.
- You have to do this thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah. They fit
good mom. They fit good.
You couldn't tell.
- You can take the tag off now. Yeah.
- So we, you know, I wanted
to give them everything.
My older ones, you know, when I was
a young mother in my early thirties.
- Yeah.
- And I come to find out
now, as a 60 year old mother
of a nine year old, that
making the world so smooth and
without a bump for them doesn't
serve them and adulthood.
It really doesn't.
And I was much too much
of a lenient mother
with my older ones, and
much too much
in trying to repair my own
childhood through mothering them.
- Wow.
- And now I have a little
daughter who has autism.
She's nine years old, and, you know,
her autism is magical to me
because it forces me sort of to slow down
to take the time
to really see the world from
another person's perspective.
And you have to, because
it's like she came
with an operating system that
my computer didn't understand,
you know?
- Yeah.
- So we had to sort of
figure out how to be there
for each other and how to make her scene.
And I know autism is
often a horrific diagnosis
for some families and some children.
It's just the, the flavor
that I got of this little baby
is such a good fit with me.
You know, I always say
I go to get her tested
every few years because
everybody says to me,
"She doesn't have autism."
I'm like, "Okay. But she does."
They're like, "No, she doesn't.
"She speaks so well."
I'm like, that's not really-
- Well, there's different-
- Yeah. It's a spectrum.
There's a whole variety of ways.
And so when I take her
to get tested, I go,
"She's mild now, right? Not moderate.
She's mild now?"
They go, "Nope, she's moderate."
"Still gonna be moderate, gonna
be moderate her whole life.
"It's a brain set up.
"There's nothing you can do."
- Yeah.
But, you know, it's a magical
different way of living.
It's like an alien dropped
from above into my life.
- Yeah.
And I've learned to speak
the language and I love it.
- I think that's really cool.
- Yeah. It's amazing.
I'd love you to meet her.
- Yeah. Well, our kid, our
daughters are on the same age.
- It would be great.
And this is how my daughter
introduces herself to the world.
Anyone, she walks straight
up to a kid on a playground.
I'm River, do you wanna be friends?
And like literally like,
there's no requirement.
She doesn't require you to do anything,
just you have to exist.
- It's so funny.
- She loves people.
Well she gets that honestly.
- Yeah, she gets that from you, right?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- We were at a hotel in the big hotel pool
and I was sitting in the
lounge watching her swim
and she swims up to everyone.
And all of a sudden I hear
like, "Rosie O'Donnell,"
like in the distance, "Rosie O'Donnell."
And I look and she's smiling and waving
and with this whole family.
And I go, "Come here.
"What are you doing?"
She goes, "Well, I told
them that, you know-"
- My daughter does that!
- Okay. So I say to her,
"Honey you don't have
"to tell everyone I'm your mommy.
"They're gonna love you for you.
"You don't have to tell 'em."
She goes, "Mom, it works for me."
(laughter)
- She was like, "But they get
my daughter, I told her we
were literally in a pool
- And then she ends up telling this woman
and I'm at the other of the
pool and I'm like, "Hi."
And yeah, she tells 'em, she's like,
"Well, they get excited. It's fun."
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "Okay," but I
don't wanna shame her for it.
But I'm like, "Can you stop." - Yeah.